nationale près de 41% des électeurs
étaient encore indécis à moins d'une
semaine du scrutin
en amérique latine toujours au pérou la
colère ne retourne pas contre la
compagnie pétrolière repsol la société
espagnole est à l'origine d'une vaste
marée noire sur les côtes du pays elle a
promis de terminer en mars des
opérations de nettoyage alors que l'
enquête se poursuit et s'annonce longue
fransat stevic
un seul coupable repsol ce vendredi sur
la place en de martin en plein centre de
la capitale des centaines de
manifestants protestent contre la
compagnie pétrolière espagnole
repsol a fait est un crime et un outrage
dans lequel elle a pollué et ce qui est
malheureux c'est que les dirigeants du
pays le pouvoir législatif n'a pas réagi
à la hauteur des actes il ne s'est pas
fait respecter dire repsol vous avez
polluée vous payez ils n'ont pas tenu
bon le pouvoir exécutif ne sais pas non
plus manifester
cette image qui a circulé dans toute la
planète où l'on ramassé les déchets avec
une petite pelle en métal est encore
d'actualité sur les plages aujourd'hui
trois semaines après la catastrophe
le 15 janvier dernier lors du
déchargement d'un tank air dans la
raffinerie de la pente pia situe à 30 km
au nord de lima une fuite de pétrole se
produit au total ce sont l'équivalent de
12 mille barils qui se déverse dans
l'océan
une nappe de pétrole poussée par les
courants jusqu'à 140 km au nord de la
raffinerie sur la côte péruvienne des
milliers de poissons et d'oiseaux marins
sont touchés beaucoup d'entre eux sont
arrivés en très mauvais état ce qui rend
difficile leur manipulation un désastre
écologique et des centaines de pêcheurs
et commerçants qui se retrouvent au
chômage forcé rapidement un coupable et
désigné le propriétaire de la raffinerie
le groupe pétrolier espagnol repsol ce
dernier rejette la responsabilité de
l'accident sur la forte houle présente
en mer ce jour là des vagues causées par
la puissante éruption volcanique aux
îles tonga qui a provoqué un tsunami
dans le pacifique
jeudi l'entreprise a promis de terminer
le mois prochain des opérations
nettoyage
nous apportons plus de 200 tonnes de
matériel pour extraire le pétrole nous
avons affrété des vols de houston de
miami d'alaska d'uruguay de finlande
tout ce qui est nécessaire pour contenir
la marée noire lundi les autorités
péruviennes ont annoncé que les
opérations de chargement et de
déchargement d'hydrocarbures en mer par
la compagnie repsol était suspendue
jusqu'à ce qu'elles fournissent les
garanties techniques qu une autre marée
noire ne se reproduira pas une mesure
jugée disproportionnée et déraisonnable
par l'entreprise espagnole qui fournit
près de 40% du marché péruvien de
carburant en attendant le tanker battant
pavillon italien à l'origine de la
catastrophe et retenu au pérou pour
enquête
dans une décision rendue le 28 janvier
dernier la justice péruvienne a interdit
à quatre responsables du groupe repsol
dont son président au pérou de sortir du
pays pendant 18 mois le temps de
poursuivre les investigations sur la
marée noire
retour en france avec la mission
relative à la régulation du prix des
carburants et du gaz dans les
départements d'outre-mer alors entamer
ses travaux et doit rendre ses premiers
résultats pour la fin mars reportage
justement en guadeloupe signé lives and
cheap rica à maurice dexter et marco du
lard
10 centimes supplémentaires pour le
super sans plomb même chose pour le
gazole nouvelle flambée des prix à la
pompe en guadeloupe le prix du gaz
augmente lui aussi 26 euros 73 ce
dimanche contre 25 euros 13 en janvier
dernier une situation devenue
insupportable pour les habitants de
l'île mike parce que c'est une époque
war nous pouvons vraiment vous des bas
salaires aïe aïe aïe avec ce plan nous
vivons en ce moment lorsqu'on à voir les
prix qui à moi quand ça demande d'où ça
sort on en a besoin que ça sera du
pétrole du gaz et autres c'est un
service qu'on ne peut pas s'en passer
mais les prix nous démontre à se trouve
ça lamentable après que les dents les
premières que les gens se chauffent
mangent les sens enfin tout ce qui sert
pour que les gens vivent monte monte
monte et du coup ça devient plus le
pouvoir d'achat des gens descendent du
coup après je sais que c'est les marchés
qui font que sur les sur les bourses qui
font que ça monte et ça descend ce que
je comprends pas c'est pourquoi ça monte
et ça descend au détriment des plus
petits gens depuis 2009 ces fluctuations
sont monnaies courantes en outre-mer des
augmentations qui touche le pouvoir
d'achat des ménages mais qui ont
également un impact certain sur le
budget des professionnels du transport
un secteur déjà bien fragilisé par la
crise sanitaire particuliers comme
professionnels attendent désormais des
mesures fortes de la part des autorités
on se doute bien qu'ils arrivent à 2 53
euros le litre personne ne va pouvoir
faire son plat donc
il faut pouvoir réguler ça je pense que
c'est des choses qui sont tout à fait
faisable là on est en train de nous
parler d'un litre de carburant par
exemple en france hexagonale qu'à un
euro 80 qui avoisine les 2 roues même
car déjà même dépasser les 2 euros par
endroits mais en même temps on n'entend
que leclerc arrive à brader et faire un
lieu de carburant à un euro donc là on
va vraiment commencer à se poser des
questions sur la formation des prix
sachant que complet trop on prend un peu
trop juste trop l'état aussi à son voile
à jouer puisque les taxes les taxes
représentent
une belle parade si quand même du prix
des carburants donc l'état devrait
pouvoir intervenir de façon à ce qu'on
régule ça et que ce soit accessible et
que ça reste accessible pour tout le
monde la mission de régulation des prix
du gouvernement doit compléter des
mesures déjà en vigueur visant à limiter
l'impact de la hausse des prix sur le
pouvoir d'achat des consommateurs
ultramarins 100 euros d'indemnités ont
été proposés pour les français dont le
revenu est inférieur à 2000 euros sans
oublier un chèque énergie 200 euros
également à destination de 281 7000
ménages ultramarins
le pouvoir d'achat plus que jamais la
préoccupation première des français pour
l'élection présidentielle la campagne
suit son cours avec un nouveau meeting
cet après midi celui de fabien roussel à
marseille le candidat communiste a
défendu ses idées devant 3500 à 4000
partisans parmi ces propositions
revalorisation du smic à 1500 euros nets
cinq cent mille emplois supplémentaires
dans les services publics ou encore
augmentation des petites pensions à 1200
euros nets à face à certains militants
et soutiens d'arnaud montebourg qui ont
rejoint sa cause le chef de file du pcn
les pcr prône également le
rétablissement de l'impôt sur la fortune
oui nous établirons liesse et on montre
et doublera
oui
oui on aurait vite à venir à la justice
la justice fiscale oran dans l' impôt
plus juste plus progressif plus léger
pour les petits et plus lourd pour les
plus gros avec vous les possibles de
vendredi et les gros fait robot
fini les cadeaux en gav à bourgueil
consorts terminée ils paieront un
meeting de fabien roussel qui intervient
au lendemain de celui de marine le pen à
reims et celui et eric zemmour à lille
samira chabihha
une démonstration de force en son et
lumière pour eric zemmour à lille le
candidat de reconquête s'est livré à une
diatribe contre l'assistanat devant plus
de 6000 personnes
dans les classes les plus populaires
jusqu'aux classes moyennes on délaisse
l'assistanat en consoler chaque matin à
5 heures pour aller travailler quand on
gagne difficilement sa vie à la sueur de
son front on n'accepte pas que le voisin
vivre mieux que soi grâce à des aides
sociales sans avoir besoin
la valorisation de l'effort avec un clin
d'oeil au mantra de nicolas sarkozy de
2007 travailler plus pour gagner plus
comme un appel du pied aussi aux
électeurs de valérie pécresse eux aussi
sensible au sujet et qui dit retrouver
du pouvoir d'achat dit aussi pour eric
zemmour cesser de gaspiller l'argent
public
parmi ces dépenses roll mes amis vous le
savez
tous les français le savent il y a le
financement de l'immigration oui mes
amis sauvé le pouvoir d'achat des
français s'est également arrêté de
financer l'immigration sur votre dos
c'est arrêter de dilapider l'argent
brille dans vos poches
on appelle cette ville pour nourrir le
monde entier
à plus de 200 km au sud reims ville du
sacre des rois de france la candidate du
rassemblement national à d'entrée de jeu
voulu marquer son style plus offensif
contre ses adversaires à commencer par
l'actuel chef de l'état
bousculés à l'intérieur humilié à
l'extérieur la france dégringole dans le
classement des puissances un publi par
les erreurs la vanité et le cynisme des
manuels macron
je ne crains ni les trahisons ni les
embuscades ni les manoeuvres je n'ai
comme boussole que l'intérêt supérieur
de notre pays et de notre peuple la
france nous attend baisse de la tva sur
le gaz et les carburants aide aux
familles monoparentales pas de retraite
en dessous de 1000 euros pendant plus
d'une heure marine le pen a égrainé ces
mesures devant un électorat populaire
déjà acquis à sa cause comme pour son
rival à lille réhausser le pouvoir
d'achat passe par une lutte contre la
fraude et l'immigration va politique en
matière d'immigration
tiendra en trois principes à la france
restera maîtresse de sa politique
migratoire
2 les étrangers qui veulent venir
devront subvenir à leurs besoins
3 c'est nous qui déciderons qui peut
rester ou qui doit partir
à la fin de son discours celle qui se
présente pour la troisième fois à
l'élection présidentielle a étonné le
public avec une parenthèse personnelle
éloigné du pupitre la voix basse elle
est revenu sur son enfance et ses échecs
un moment d'intimité pour fendre
l'armure étoffer son capital sympathie
et peut-être se démarquer d'un rival
toujours aussi menaçants dans les
intentions de vote
contre vote celui de l'assemblée
nationale qui se prononce contre
l'octroi de l'asile à julian assange une
résolution transpartisane appelé le
gouvernement français à ce à accorder
l'asile politique aux lanceurs d alerte
australien a co fondateur de wikileaks
détenu au royaume uni dans l'attenté
d'une possible extradition vers les
etats-unis où il risque jusqu'à 175 ans
de prison plus de précision avec meriem
laribi
une certaine gêne s'est fait sentir dans
les rangs de la majorité présidentielle
dont les députés et le ministre franck
riester venu représenter le gouvernement
ont expliqué à quel point ils étaient
favorables à la protection des lanceurs
d'alerté à quel point assange méritait
tout notre soutien mais ils ont avancé
ce qu'ils ont appelé des points
litigieux d'ordre juridique ou
diplomatique ils ont principalement
argumenté en fait qu accorder l'asile ne
relevait pas de l'exécutif mais
mais de l'autre harkis et l'office
français de protection des réfugiés et
des apatrides et sont rentrés dans une
foule de détails disant qu'il fallait
que le demandeur d'asile se trouve sur
le sol français pour faire sa demande
pour les députés de la majorité qui se
sont exprimés donner le statut de
réfugié politique à julian assange
reviendrait à ne pas reconnaître
l'impartialité des deux systèmes
judiciaires américains et britanniques
et ça vous comprenez c'est gênant c'est
donc au royaume uni de décider du cas d'
assange selon eux et la france n'a pas à
faire preuve d'ingérence on a connu
quand même vous vous en souvenez la
majorité présidentielle et le
gouvernement français ce gouvernement en
tout cas bien plus véhéments lorsqu'il
s'agissait de critiquer le break site
pourtant décision souveraine du peuple
britannique ou encore bien plus véhément
et intrusif lorsqu'il s'agit de soutenir
l'opposant russe alexis navalni ou
encore de reconnaître le l'opposant juan
garrido comme président du venezuela
donc on peut dire que selon le sujet
traité et le pays la gérance la
non-ingérence de ce gouvernement semble
semble à géométrie variable pour le plus
grand malheur de julian assange est
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve dans une
trentaine de minutes à 21h et stephen
harper france
[Musique]
un certain nombre de journalistes
semblent s'être octroyé à un pouvoir de
juger un pouvoir même de condamner c'est
extrêmement dangereux parce que moi
j'aime savoir d'où parle les gens j'ai
cherché j'ai essayé de trouver des
réponses mais émettra 20 suis jamais à
oger une qualité ou une compétence ou
une expertise que je n'avais pas je
pense que notre métier devrait un peu
douté de ses bases et les revoir et les
remettre en question toujours eu un rôle
historique pour le meilleur et pour le
pire d'ailleurs parce que si on était un
petit allemands dans les années 30 on
l'a beaucoup entendu hitler et ses potes
à la radio puis toutes les choses graves
j'ai l'impression qu'on les apprend par
la radio quand on écoute la radio c'est
si c'est grave ou si c'est pas grave
plus qu'à la télé
[Musique]
l'afrique la nouvelle crypte hollande on
a l'impression d'assister un phénomène
de mode qui est amenée à durer
véritablement sur le continent nous
sommes juste entré dans une nouvelle ère
du système financier et la population
africaine c'est un milliard d'habitants
c'est ça à la valeur de nos krypton
mener notre objectif c'est d'avoir de
plus en plus de partenaires qui
acceptent notre crypto comme moyen de
paiement qu'en ce crash qui nous dit que
l'argent liquide perd de la valeur
beaucoup de pays en afrique on
t'interdit
la crypto est ce que vous répondez à
cela une canette on ne peut pas dire on
va interdire la crypto autant qu'il ya
internet il y aura des trucs
[Musique]